[Music]
there are so many complexities within
the cannabis industry cannabis science
and more specifically cannabis
microbiology does not need to be one
today i join you to share how you can
make cannabis microbiology simple
while meeting your unique
state compliance regulations
protecting consumer health and safety as
well as protecting your brand and
profitability
i'm maria mcintyre strategic business
manager of cannabis and hemp for biomary
u
today we'll look at several factors
first off why care about microbiology
health and safety for all the impact of
microbiology testing
safety and mitigation as well as that
simple science
so you may be asking yourself
why
are
microbiology
microbes are present everywhere
microbes including pathogens molds fungi
can have a negative impact on human
health in your brand
microbes are present in
agricultural products
and they also are
present throughout the supply chain and
there's many points throughout that
supply chain from seed to consumption
where there's opportunity to
review and understand the microbes to
mitigate risks and improve product
quality brand reputation as well as
consumer safety
so let's look at what we've learned from
the pandemic
you may actually know more about
microbiology
than you might think
little things can harm you
and
subtle changes can leave
large impact so if we look at covid
that the covid virus can be very harmful
when we put small changes in place such
as mask wearing and hand washing and
vaccinations
they leave a large impact on the health
and safety of a population
it's similar in cannabis microbiology
small things
can harm you
your product and your brand and with
subtle changes you can impact the the
safety
the your brand and and your product
quality
microbiology
organisms that can't be visible to the
naked eye
this includes the classification of of
several groups including bacteria
viruses fungi and others again all
classified as microbes
microbes are present everywhere and they
can impact the quality of your product
as well as
the the health of people
quite frankly they can even be deadly
as with any agricultural
product microbes are present throughout
the supply chain and there's
opportunities
microbes to have both and flourish
throughout
as with any
agricultural products microbes are
present
their value
understands what their opportunities to
grow are
and to predict the challenges within
your environment
when you do this and mitigate the risks
it turns a higher product quality
maintains brand
image as well as
helps you protect consumer health and
safety as well as profitability
one key microbe of interest within the
cannabis industry is aspergillus and
aspergillus can lead to
aspergilliosis which in
many individuals can cause serious side
effects or even death so it's critical
to understand your environment to make
those small changes to further impact
your brand profitability and consumer
health and safety
another element to consider
is that the adult use market has a wide
variety of consumers and this may
include
medicinal
consumers
we truly never know
who is on the
consumption end of the products
so
the intention would be to protect all
protect your brand and avoid any
financial impact and
negative supply chain disruption
so why test cannabis we test cannabis
for several reasons
first many tests for
simply meeting the state compliance
regulations
the testing can be used for impact
consumer health and safety
also to improve the the quality of your
product to safeguard the industry
and to fuel your
your brand image and profitability
compliance testing is needed to meet
state regulations protect consumers and
your brand
regulations are patchworked throughout
the the united states each state has a
different schematic for
regulations
given the diversity in regulations it's
imperative to know compliance
regulations in your states of operations
the cannabis industry is so dynamic no
one knows exactly where regulations will
be in the short term more or less the
long term
looking at and understanding regulations
holistically in the united states can be
impactful and provide you a different
perspective so let's take a look here
if we look at the current regulations
for microbiologies they fall into
several categories if we look at
pathogen testing these are predominantly
salmonella stick as well as aspergillus
and the aspergillus contains usually
four select species for for
considerations if we move beyond
pathogen testing we move into the the
threshold testing of yeast and mold and
other parameters where there's a
required count and acceptance limits
and
adjacent these two
two categories of testing we're seeing
that accreditation overall is required
for the iso 17025
and the expanding work within aoac to
validate the fit for purpose of select
testing methods
if we move further into other trends we
see that a lot of regulations for the
microbial parameters
include product
and categories so you may have a
different type of testing to be done for
an edible versus an inhalable and
various other types of of product
in some cases we do see that
the the
method in states are
accepted or declined so take as you're
looking at the regulations take a close
look here as well
compliance testing is endpoint testing
to ensure the quality of your product
and protect your brand profitability and
consumers both now and in the future
it's important to talk about
in-house testing when you test in-house
it creates the opportunity for you to
understand your environment and
operations
discover mitigate and ensure and even
sometimes predict challenges that may
appear in your operation this is
relevant from seed to sale
from soil to air cultivation harvest
drying
curing and beyond there are risks to
quality and safety that impact your
brand and reputation proactively testing
for microbial organisms allows you to
mitigate these risks and again even
predict these changes this helps to
avoid compliance failures and recalls
this also fuels brand protections and
give your customers and yourself the
peace of mind knowing that your product
can be trusted
let's take a look at the three
categories pre-harvest post harvest and
processing
so if we look at the pre-harvest side of
things it's important to
look in knowing your environment also
test your growth mediums including cocoa
core soil tissue culture and beyond take
a look at your incoming materials they
they could be posing risk to
initial phases as well as downstream
it's important to know and understand
the microbial climate within your mother
room as well as
that is an anchor for all of your
operations from the cultivation side
there's many tools out there in
pre-harvest to help you look at
beneficial insects and integration of a
pest management program
if we move from pre-harvest to
post-harvest environmental monitoring
is still important as well as
understanding incoming new materials
that are relevant within this phase
surveillance testing is also impactful
understanding that the quality
throughout your cycle and really fueling
your quality program throughout your
operations
from pre-harvest we move into processing
and here also environmental
monitoring is very impactful as well as
looking at additional ingredients that
are brought into
to your product as well as packaging
testing
this
within processing you can also look at
the final product before that is sent
out for
compliance testing also another element
to look at in the processing category
would be shelf life tests this includes
the stability of your your product and
determines a shelf life for
functionality as well as quality
this brings us back to why test
cannabis for
microbiological contaminants this
includes the meeting of the state and
local compliance regulations the
insurance of consumer health and safety
the
confirmation of product
quality
as well as safeguarding the cannabis
industry and these collectively fuel
into protecting your brand image and
profitability
now that you know the more harmful risks
of microbes the regulations the options
for impacting your
operations let's look at factors to
consider in selecting a microbiology
testing method with the variation from
state to state it's impactful to
understand
how to choose the right method to
analyze those microbial contaminants
that you're looking for
there are three main areas to consider
when selecting a microbiology solution
for testing cannabis these are testing
simplicity to meet regulations and also
to achieve your operational goals this
is connected to science and the
reliability of results and scientific
integrity
combined with aoac
this moves us forward into
those two factors influencing the
efficiency and optimization as well as
having a microbiology
partner
let's dive in a little bit further
when you select simple and reliable
solutions these are easy to operate and
adapt into your operations there's
minimal time and labor
and it speaks to the variety of
capabilities of your staff
understanding the method and workflow
adjacent the time labor and level of
expertise will really impact the success
of your operations reliability is a
critical factor for you to
trust
your results and your solutions this
begins with the science
when you look at robust and reliable
science combined with simple and
reliable methods it increases the safety
and compliance throughout your
operations there's also value here to
mention innovation as we
now know what regulations look like and
build to
fuel the the diversity and dynamics
within the expanding industry in a
innovation is a critical pillar having a
partner that can help you with
customized assays and innovation is
imperative to move with you with the
dynamic times scientific integrity and
aoac are the backbones to a testing
methods this yields strong and accurate
results that are reliable for you and
scientific integrity this is seen from
data from the vendor as well as data and
certification through aoac specific to
cannabis related products it's important
to ensure
that your testing method is fit for
purpose and will perform the functions
that you need so let's take a deeper
look
on aoac aoac has rapidly changed within
the last year
and
looking at who aoac is
why
aoac is operating in the cannabis
industry to support science really leads
us to
the value of aoac
aoac establishes standard method
analysis this impacts health and safety
for all
this globally recognized organization
has
scientific
processes to
scrutinize and analyze
fit for purpose within
a testing method there are numerous
other elements that aoac provides in
value since we're focusing on selecting
a testing method we'll keep it simple
and leave it at that for today
aoac also contributes to
product safety
aoac unites industry academia and others
to establish testing validation it
ensures that you have reliable testing
methods for the purpose and
functionality there with this it brings
a strong impact to public health and
safety and ensures that scientific
integrity within cannabis
through other industries and throughout
the globe this bridges further with the
cannabis industry
in
the scientific relevance of testing
methods aoac brings a significant value
and knowledge to the cannabis industry
this includes method testing validation
reliable analytical
options for testing methods that ensure
both the science and safety that then
impact
and
protect consumers the industry and the
products
let's move into the last factor to
consider
for selecting a microbial testing method
efficiency and optimization are
essential as well as ensuring you're
selecting a partner that is truly a
partner that will support you and
provide you access to scientific
expertise and real-time
troubleshooting a partner is an
extension of your operations and your
laboratory so to look a little bit
further into operations and efficiency
ultimately this is doing doing more with
less with less steps with less
materials with less process
that efficiency and optimization can be
fueled by
simplified workflows
having a simple process for testing
microbiology really impacts your
confidence in the test as well as the
optimization of
your operations having a workflow as
simple as from going from sample to
results with a few simple steps
along the way is really imperative to
fuel this forward
having that microbial expertise and that
partnership for someone knowing the
cannabis industry as well as several
other industries including food pharma
nutraceutical
all anchored in the the science of
microbiology
is an opportunity to take you further
faster it allows you to have greater
profitability productivity and increased
quality as well as that partnership that
was mentioned to be an extension of your
operations to further influence that
bigger picture and your operational
goals
we've talked about three areas to focus
on in selecting a method in terms of the
simplicity of the the testing to meet
regulations
and also your operational goals the
second being reliability and scientific
integrity
adjacent to aoac and then lastly the
efficiency and optimization and benefits
of that microbial
scientific partner
considering these three factors will
really set you and your operation up for
success today we've touched on a lot of
topics including starting with why care
about microbiology testing in the
cannabis industry
how that influences
consumer safety your brand image not
only today but also in the future and
the impacts of cannabis microbiology
testing
that also impacts your operational goals
through science and looking at the
simplicity of science
and how that allows you to reach your
current goals and build for the future
while driving optimization really
appreciate your time today we've talked
about a lot of areas as you ponder this
conversation please feel free to
reach out to me directly to expand this
conversation further
thank you
you